[Music]
it's not every day you can say you're
making a milkshake release you were
still jamming to that song be a part of
something that I mean like girls like
kids come up to me but it's like it
still works and it still has such a you
know the beat is strong and it's funny I
know a lot of fans out there want to
know are you working on any new music
you know always writing and I'm always
kind of like I mean yeah I stay in the
studio just sort of creating but I don't
know what I'm cooking that's right
making milkshakes you love to cook and I
learned that you graduate from a cordon
bleu yes that's so crazy I mean where
did this passion for cooking and food
come from I mean I'm a New Yorker my
moms are sad I grew up around a lot of
different food and access to a lot of
different stuff so when I had the time I
just decided to go to culinary school
and I fell in love with just I think
being able to create in a different form
we can obsess what do you love to cook
the most well I'm a saucier I make
sauces so that's what I'm doing for I'm
a sauce company and everything's bad
sauce ain't that the truth I also got a
cookbook I have a bad luck that's called
my life on a plate and it really is you
know touring and you just music took me
around the world the book is really
about like my favorite things from
traveling and things I picked up and
then stuff I grew up eating you know
from New York and for my mom like I said
the chef and yeah it's kind of it's the
culmination of my life
we're gonna put those recipes skills to
the test what would make it today well
obviously it's national chocolate
milkshake day so I wanted to do
something decadent and really rich and
lush I decided to make my chocolate
milkshake now I'm interested and you're
actually a spokesperson right yes okay
so here we've got we've got chocolate
ice cream so we're just gonna add this
in here
is never too much no we've got our liver
here so how much record you actually put
in this thing you know I would say we're
gonna measure it will do like two
depends on what time of day it is not
honestly I put a little ginger beer in
there that's so crystal I've never heard
of a milk shake with jinwu before that's
some bubbles and we'll flavor there
yeah it just gives it a nice kick this
is some candied ginger and then just a
little bit here this is cayenne you like
it spicy huh I do I love it I'm with you
put some ice in there just and then you
blend all right well you've been doing
all the work TV magic by the way we got
our milkshakes
I can't wait to get into this but first
we gotta add some whipped cream right
yeah see you got that man okay this is
the industrial one you guys are no joke
with this okay here we go
wish me luck
first losing milkshake I cannot wait
here we go are you kidding me right
whoa that has like a little kick to it
yeah but is so good it's gonna bring all
the boys to the yard away oh I had to
Cheers thanks for this milk
[Music]